all right so let's begin Bismillah
science and scientism
now the first thing I like to talk about
is definitions
um that's the first thing anyone should
do especially when going to
philosophical inquiry
and the reason that definitions are
important is because you don't really
understand what's going on unless of
course you understand your terms
now uh before going to that as well
um
two things this is probably going to be
one of the most important topics you
learn when trying to understand atheism
and I'm not just saying that because I'm
teaching the course but yes if you want
me to flatter myself that's fine
this is the most important subject is
because this deals with the epistemology
or the way in which atheists understand
the world
um most atheists today most contemporary
atheists believe that most or all
knowledge can be asked can be
derived from science itself from the
methodology of science itself so if you
do not understand science or how
atheists think about science then you
won't understand atheism
at all or how atheists think in general
secondly disclaimer even after this
course you're not going to know
everything about science and scientism
this is a very basic course we're not
going to get through much within two
hours we're going to do as best as we
can
um but this should give you some
Foundation
all right so let's begin with
definitions all right actually first
Thomas Kuhn
one of my favorite philosophers and he
said something very uh wise and uh it
seemed it doesn't seem like it's wise
but think about it the answer you get
depends on the questions you ask and I
hope that people ask many many many
questions during this lecture you could
you don't have to ask them at the end of
the lecture you can ask them anytime you
can even ask them about random things I
like to rant so that's fine as well as
long as it's not too off topic okay
we'll be discussing Thomas later as
well
what is science okay first definition
should be basic enough right
all right you guys need to know this the
intellectual and practical activity
encompassing the systematic study of the
structure and behavior of the physical
and natural world through observation
and experiments that's it for those of
you who may be science Majors maybe in
the medical field this shouldn't be
surprising to you in the least all right
so
let's move on to the next definition
which is going to be the most important
one we'll be discussing
here we go what is scientism
all right so what's the difference
the belief that the methods of natural
science or the categories and things
recognized in Natural Science form the
only proper elements in any
philosophical or other inquiry in other
words for for concise format science is
the only or best way to know anything
that's it that's really the only part
you have to memorize there but uh
that's the general definition of
scientism
now before going to the the nature of
Sciences the specifics about what
science and scientism are I want to
discuss kind of how science influences
the way that we think and how we
perceive it in the Contemporary period
so
is scientism a big deal is it something
that we're just like making up right now
is it something that um has no real
manifestation in the world is it
something that people even think about
well honestly most people are affected
by this belief system uh whether they
explicitly Believe it or it's just sort
of like something that they they've sort
of subconsciously uh had from education
or from the surrounding culture
so all of us are actually affected by
this uh concept known as scientism
so let me show you
how that is a case
firstly though
this is what atheists generally think
about science
okay
so here we have one of the new atheists
one of the well-known atheist
um among the new atheist crowd you know
Richard Dawkins uh Sam Harris
Christopher Hitchens
his name was Victor stenger the late
Victor Stanger and he pretty much
concisely summarized what new atheists
believe about science and the concept of
God and he said the new atheist firmly
insists that the personal abrahamic or
Islamic God is a scientific hypothesis
that can be tested by the standard
methods of science so they honestly
believe
most of the atheists today that the
concept of God and religion everything
else that comes with it is actually a
scientific hypothesis
they actually believe this
so this is the the more explicit form of
scientism coming out
so let's see how it affects us
what's the attraction to science
many of you think about science every
day you just don't realize it or when
you do you think about in a very
different manner
power
the attraction to science has a lot to
do with power what does that mean
well let's think about what are the most
powerful nations in the world today
the ones with what
the biggest weapons
most technology
most economic power
right that's one of the biggest ways in
which science influences us we don't
realize it technology already mentioned
communication what we're doing right now
how I'm communicating with all of you is
actually quite amazing if you think
about it
did you know that only like we've only
had this technology for what the past
what was it was it since the 90s
not even
that's amazing you know we we take it
for granted but you have to really
consider how much we've Advanced
technologically over the past few
decades I remember when the first cell
phones came out they were bigger than my
head
um
yeah that was really embarrassing nobody
wanted one back then it was like the
first time when the iPad came out
you know nobody really wanted to carry
that big thing
but now everyone has it
thankfully they got smaller as well
um anyways so yeah and the internet the
internet's an amazing thing you know
before email guess how we communicate
with each other it's insane a lot of you
are too young to remember that
I remember working on the first Mac
that was horrible it was nice back then
but it was horrible in compared to you
know to now
uh health
we lived in the first time in human
history where you can be as unhealthy as
possible and still live to average age
that's amazing
so use many Twinkies as you want people
because you will live up to 70.
wealth something we already kind of
mentioned
um being able to process wealth being
able to earn wealth through our
technology through the healthcare
it's horrible in here in the United
States though a lot of exploitation you
know occurring through the insurance
companies Etc but well so the attraction
to science has a lot to do with all of
these
and when we see all of this
we kind of
have this idea in our minds that it has
to do with or ethics or our cultural
values like it they're almost the same
thing you know like the reason that we
have all this power and technology and
health and wealth is because
we are in some way or another virtuous
or
or civilized you know
so the worldly benefits of scientific
and technological output allows people
to feel a sense of power control and
superiority over those who lack such
things the correlation between these
society's ideas and this output often
creates a necessary causal Link in the
mind between the two in other words a
base value evaluation is made without
concern for other factors that lead to
these results
so when we look at the world when we
look at our scientific progress we often
think to ourselves how advanced we are
how awesome we are
but we don't ever think about the values
behind those things we don't think about
how we got to that point
so let me kind of wake you guys up a
little bit
but what about this
pollution
you've been having some major problems
in the world today with pollution
why are we not considering that part of
our scientific advancement why do we
think when we think about science why do
we not think about this aspect
why do we focus on all the benefits cell
phones but we don't focus on how that
technology and how those things are made
and what the damage is doing towards to
our environment
even when you looked on the media when
they talk about uh pollution when they
talk about the ozone layer do they blame
any aspects of the scientific Enterprise
or do they blame humans they blame
specifically Humanity
humans own errors
and of course that's a rational thing to
do but they never tie it to science the
only time science has ever tied to
anything
usually is when it causes a benefit
is that a realistic picture
not really because science even when it
causes benefits is still the hands of
humans right
but you never hear it from that
perspective
you always hear science is doing this
but you never hear what people are doing
necessarily
there's never a human hand it's always
shown as sort of this objective neutral
thing outside you know that's causing
all these benefits but it's completely
separated from the negativity
at least that's how media presents it
so pollution we have a huge pollution
problem in the world today is actually
if you didn't already know this
um the ozone layers the ozone lanes are
actually correcting itself now
alhamdulillah but uh
and hopefully you know eventually we're
all going to switch to electric cars
anyway
so that'll even go it'll heal itself
even further and hopefully global
warming will get less of an issue
but uh yeah we had snow I live in the
south here in America
and we had three days of snow like it
wasn't really thick but it was enough to
be like okay why am I living down here
you know it's supposed to be warm
um so you can see that even the
environment when you look around it's
becoming
a lot more varied in terms of
temperatures and in terms of weather
conditions and even the hurricanes are
getting horrible now have you seen the
size of the hurricanes
it's you okay go online later on after
this lecture look online about the size
of hurricanes and you can see there's a
massive difference over the past 10 20
years literally
hurricane sizes have doubled
um it's it's it's incredible
all right so let's move on what else
wmds I think this is self-explanatory
but
let me make this clear that a lot of
people don't think about this aspect
of science unless of course
they're only talking about you know
Warfare but most people in the daily
lives do not think of Science in this
way
but this is one of the
major impacts of scientific Enterprise
over the past couple of years
now going back to history again many of
you are too young I'm too young to
remember this but I've studied history
but you know World War II wasn't that
long ago guys
um it wasn't that long ago
um it was less than 100 years ago
and
the atomic bombs pictures of those which
you're seeing right here aren't dropped
very long ago and they killed hundreds
of thousands of people
um this is a real this is a reality that
many of you take for granted and believe
it or not many of the major powers in
the world are only powerful because they
have hundreds of these lying around
Underground
that's a pretty disturbing thing
next
um
exploitation
we don't think about that either we look
at our food production values we look at
the way in which our technology is made
but if you actually
think about where you're getting your
phones if you think about where you're
getting most of your technology it's not
in a very ethical manner
I feel guilty for holding this right now
but it's not a very ethical manner
um
most of the
sounds of the achievements that we have
in terms of Technology were built by the
hands of individuals who do not have the
same rights as you as you or I
for instance children if you go on many
of the southeast Southeast Asian
countries I travel the world a bit so
I've seen a lot of these things like in
Malaysia you find that
a lot of
people who should who are not of the age
to be working are working
a lot of exploitation is occurring with
immigrant labor and things like this a
lot of the technology you have which you
know I'm not I'm not trying to make
everyone feel guilty but
you know it's being it's it's it's
produced in a very unethical manner
but we don't understand it that way
because the way that we perceive signs
once again is separated from the values
of a society
okay so there's little concern for these
atrocities and more focus on the
benefits they produce while there is a
minority attempting to stop these
horrible practices many individuals
living in scientifically Advanced
societies have little to no concern
um
so in a way this is how scientism kind
of affects us in an indirect manner by
by allowing us to separate our
understanding of science from the ethics
behind it
we'll get into the reason why in a
moment here
and uh and the reason I'm speaking about
scientism first because before I get
into what science is I have to explain
what science is not because a lot of you
guys have been indoctrinated including
myself at one point about what science
is and it's not that way at all
so if you believe in scientism then you
do not understand science
okay
so yes if you're wondering if I'm
accusing some of these atheists who
follow scientism of not understanding
science I'm doing exactly that and I can
because I'm a philosopher I'm allowed to
do those things we're the most annoying
people on the planet
um you'll figure out why in a moment
you know
um
you ever go to a gathering of scientists
and there's a philosopher there he's
always by himself
what is the purpose behind this why is
this occurring how is this occurring
we don't just especially philosophical
science we don't just want to do the
science we don't just want to see the
product of science we want to be able to
understand how it got there what the
thought process was you know what what
is the theory for example what does that
mean we're going to explain what that is
later as well
you know we want to understand what is a
fact uh why is science beneficial why is
it not beneficial in certain respects
you know uh where does it get us is
science Progressive things like this and
only philosophers ask those questions
and this is why scientists are annoyed
by us is because you know all they want
to do is sit in their Labs all day
no offense to them I mean you know they
do good work
but sometimes you need a father figure
looking over you so look at let's see
what the three aspects of scientism are
so that you guys understand a little
better
and after this we're going we're going
to go into the history of scientism
you know the history behind how this
thought process began and where it ended
up
so the three aspects of scientism are
one realism
to positivism and three
uh with progressionism it's a
progressive
understanding of science so what are
these three things well let's start with
realism first okay Q awesome graphics
boom boom all right here we go
scientific theories are actual and true
representations of reality independent
of human biases I.E objective
okay so this is the first definition of
the three of the first aspect of what is
scientism is called realism scientific
realism
once again scientific theories are
actual and true representations of
reality independent of human bias they
are objective meaning
whatever theories we've constructed
whether it be about gravity uh you know
um
whatever else you can see Evolution for
example is an actual representation of
how reality is
okay independent of whatever you or I
think about it
it doesn't matter what we think it
doesn't matter how we perceive it
that's how it is
okay
seems like common sense right that's how
most people think about science to be
honest
okay so let's move on
next positivism this is really the heart
of scientism here so I need you guys to
remember this specifically we're going
to be talking about positivism a lot
more later
this is a big definition
science corresponds with rationality
itself and is the only means to verify
the truths and meanings of every
possible statement and explanation
there is there are no metaphysical
assumptions or reasons behind scientific
thought so if you had a class with the
Stars uh Hamza
uh for the last week a few days ago he
talked about metaphysical assumptions
according to scientism uh when they have
this aspect of positivism in there there
are no metaphysical assumptions there is
no metaphysics it doesn't exist there
are no abstractions
mathematics for example
it's not if it's I mean it's just it's
just it's just like a it's just symbols
um things like that there are no like
meaning is not so this abstract thing
everything that I'm saying right now for
you to understand it
according to this has to be verified
empirically scientifically like it has
to be observed
do you understand
um so if I say
well I mean this is a very obvious
example but if I say
um
my door is brown I have to be able to
you know verify that to you if I say uh
you know I'm sick right now or I'm happy
or anything even every emotion has to be
verified scientifically every claim
every statement you utter
okay
has no meaning or any sort of
content or substance unless it can be
tied to some sort of empirical
observation justified through scientific
inquiry
okay now you might be like well that's
crazy maybe maybe not
right but that is one of the essential
beliefs
okay and atheists will talk like this a
lot too
that's why they always ask can you prove
this can you provide evidence for this
everything needs evidence right
scientific evidence they're always
asking for this sort of evidence
and next
progressionism
should have wrote as progressionism but
okay so science is a cumulative
Enterprise where each Theory
builds upon prior theories in a gradual
manner
okay before we get into definition I
have a question by Abdullah Naman
to avoid the problem of scientism
positivism they reword their claim and
say it's absurd to believe anything Luke
to believe something ludicrous unless
objective evidence for it is available
how do you respond to that
uh
uh okay I'm trying to understand your
question first
uh give me a moment
you mean like extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
okay how about this how about we
continue
I'll get back to this question later I
think you want to reward this later
because you'll see how we discuss
positive and at a later point so we'll
get back to this and
let's go back to progressionism first
though
science is a cumulative Enterprise where
each Theory builds upon prior theories
in a gradual manner I think all of you
can probably admit or at least most of
you in this chat can probably admit that
this is something that you believe that
science is a cumulative process meaning
that prior theories were
you know they're correct to a degree
and then what happened is that some
other scientists came along they were
brilliant they found some new
information and they built upon the
theories and the theory just keeps
gradually building upon itself like a
building right until it goes really
really high like the Burj Khalifa okay
that's basically how people see science
it's a very gradual process
which we keep gaining knowledge and just
keep getting more and more intelligent
until we reach Star Trek or Star Wars
which is better
um
come on guys you want a lightsaber be
quiet
uh so that's what most people think
about scientism or about science